as we approach Halloween it makes sense
when discussing skin care to talk about
vampire facials which have become quite
popular as of late here to talk tell us
more about what these are from flawless
Med Spa we have Melanie speed good to
have you with us thank you along with
Jayden and Paige thank you guys for
being here as well let's talk about
vampire facials what separates a vampire
facial just from a regular one it's a
vampire facial we use microneedling
which is a tiny device that she has
right there has 13 different needles in
it and it causes what's called micro
injuries or small injuries to the skin
just enough to stimulate the production
of collagen and then we're also using
the plasma Rich protein which we get
from the blood we spin it down we take
the plasma Rich protein it has about
seven different growth factors in it and
so where we're microneedling and
creating all the little injuries we're
putting the plasma-rich protein in it
and the combination of the two causes a
stimulation and new growth of collagen
now this has been around for a while 10
years or so but became more popular
recently because Kim Kardashian posted
yeah she posted it a few years ago a lot
of celebrities have and so it's kind of
become more mainstream and people are
seeking out the treatment but it's a
really good effective treatment for
stimulating collagen that you can't
really stimulate any other way now
unless Jayden is super tough and we
don't know it it appears to be painless
it is it feels like a vibrating or
almost a tickling of the skin we offer
numbing cream with lidocaine in it so it
numbs the surface of the skin and then
we use the
microneedling device and so it feels
like a tickling or vibrating because the
skin is slightly numb yeah and so is
there a recovery period of any sort the
day that you that you do it it's like a
light sunburn the face is slightly red
and we leave the plasma Rich protein on
it for about six to eight hours after
the treatment that night you wash your
face we ask that you don't put anything
on that evening but the next day you can
put on makeup and go and not have to
worry about sun exposure or anything
like that we don't want you in the sun
directly you know wouldn't be a good day
to go to the pool but you can be in and
out going to your car going to work
things like that now Jayden Aubrey
obviously has Perfect Skin already but
what are the benefits of a vampire
facial for everybody it helps with Fine
Lines wrinkles dark spots acne scarring
just basically all the things that the
environment does to our skin over time
so it's just a great anti-aging and skin
tightening now is this is it one that is
being enjoyed by men as well as women
yes absolutely that's great all right so
thank you so much for being here Melanie
appreciate it Jayden page thank you very
much you have a special going on we do
we're running a special for the month of
October our vampire facials are usually
600 and we're running a special this
month for 400. if you'd like to try it
it's a great time absolutely yeah so
tell me uh what how long has that
benefit last after you've done it once
we usually last about six months to a
year okay that's great all right Melanie
Paige Jayden thank you very much for
being here today thank you for having us